you know what's better than adorable
little puppies watching tom hall and
play with adorable little puppies true
remain calm everybody tom sat down for a
puppy interview with buzzfeed where he
answered some fan questions or at least
tried because how can you not be
distracted when you're like surrounded
by puppies take a look we'll see you
next time
get in there guys hello beautiful guys
guys guys guys guys you can go to sleep
and live with us in my apartment
because you are gonna be
our puppy what was your question
[Music]
my favorite stunt in the uncharted look
at these dogs
stop it guys this is beautiful this
little one you so you're like me you're
the little one hello
i think this one's my favorite no no no
it's okay i'll protect you come up here
oh
little belly scratch what was your
question again what are we talking about
favorite stunts uh there's a stunt in
the movie hello this is a big one he's
gonna be a big dog my favorite stunt to
film in uncharted
oh no careful careful careful i like the
stunt where i fall at the back of the
plane i get hit by the car that was a
lot of fun it was very nerve-wracking my
mum came to see me that day
i would be in euphoria i think i'd be a
really good maddie i'm a big euphoria
fan i love the show and i love season
two i visited a lot while they were
shooting it and i really really enjoyed
it oh he's up again i would love to
guest star we'll just be an extra in it
or maybe i am you just don't know that
is so cute how is that comfortable for
him on the box no guys guys
i'm so sorry i'll protect you guys you
can go back to sleep